we start today with the beginning of the
Dominion voting systems Fox News
defamation trial this is a trial that
could have such far-ranging impact and
we're going to be watching it
extraordinarily closely now the trial
was originally scheduled to start
yesterday there was the announcement
that there would be a delay and there
was the suspicion that the delay might
be
because Fox News wanted to settle the
case and prevent it from going to trial
whether or not that's what the cause of
the delay was the case is not being
settled and the trial is set to start
today CNBC reports Fox News and Dominion
trial kicks off with opening statements
in defamation suit Dominion has accused
Fox of intentionally and falsely blaming
it for president Donald Trump's loss to
Joe Biden by airing false claims that
the company rigged the 2020 election fox
has maintained the statements made about
Dominion on air are protected by the
First Amendment the case has led to the
release of troves of private messages
and testimony from Top Fox News figures
including Fox Corporation chairman
Rupert Murdoch and opinion host Tucker
Carlson so it was a couple different
things here that are of absolutely
critical importance first of all
the mere fact that Fox News is asserting
first amendment protection isn't unique
and it's really important to understand
that there are many circumstances in
which there is defamation alleged and as
a defense the first amendment is given
that doesn't make this case special it
doesn't particularly make it about
actually actual Free Speech this is a
case in which you are alleging
defamation meaning incorrect claims
knowingly made which are harmful to the
reputation in this case of dominion with
the Counterpoint that you can always
issue as a defense to defamation
uh the truth of the claims made if it
were true that Trump won in 2020 but
because of a rigging done involving
Dominion voting systems Joe Biden became
president if you could demonstrate that
then it would by definition not be
defamation and we're going to get back
to that in a moment we are going to see
among other things likely even more
documents and text messages and
Communications come out these are the
very Communications through which we
learned that there are some True
Believers on Fox news's staff including
people like Maria Bartiromo that there
are people on Fox News staff like Tucker
Carlson who despise Donald Trump
passionately was the word Tucker used to
describe his hate for Donald Trump
and on some level
this is sort of lose-lose for Fox Now
that it's gotten to this point and what
I mean by that is if Fox were to settle
they might avoid what now might be four
to six weeks of disastrous headlines as
more evidence comes out in the trial but
they would be to some degree admitting
guilt
and the alternative is well you don't
settle but you now have six weeks of
potentially disastrous headlines and at
the end of it you still might lose oh a
whole bunch of money and your reputation
reputation could be irreparably damaged
now I to get back to that a defense to
defamation is proving the facts Donald
Trump's suggestion which he posted uh
yesterday or the day before yesterday we
talked about it yesterday the truth
social truth essential was that fox
indeed do that and say hey it's not
defamation Trump really won Trump's idea
posted on Truth Central in all capital
letters was quote if Fox would finally
admit that there was large-scale
cheating and irregularities in the 2020
presidential election which would be a
good thing for them and for America the
case against them which should not have
existed at all would be greatly weakened
back up those Patriots at Fox instead of
throwing them under the bus and they are
right there is so much proof like Mass
ballots stuff nothing caught on
government cameras FBI colluding with
Twitter and Facebook State legislatures
not used Etc now there's a couple
interesting things about this first of
all as I mentioned defamation is a legal
term false statements harmful
to someone's reputation someone accuses
you of defamation one defense is proved
that what you said is true the problem
with Trump's idea other than the fact
that Trump didn't win the November of
2020 election and so you can't prove
something that's not true this
particular case is narrowly focused on
the allegedly defamatory statements made
about Dominion voting systems
involvement many of the things Trump is
talking about here ballot stuffing FBI
colluding with Twitter even if Fox tried
to prove that in this trial it wouldn't
be a useful defense because the
allegations in question that are
allegedly defamatory are the ones about
Dominion voting systems specifically
imagine the circus that that would be
though Fox News didn't defame anyone
because Trump did win and Dominion
voting systems did do whatever Mike
pillow says that they did with the
machines like imagine the circus that
that would become Side Story here that's
an important story that I do want to
mention as well Angelo caruson
from Media Matters who we've interviewed
on the program
he has a really good Twitter thread
explaining an additional issue for Fox
News that could be disastrous and we'll
link to the Twitter thread in the
description uh for the YouTube video
where I'm talking about this Angelo
writes that parallel to this trial Fox
News is going to be renegotiating and
gearing up to renegotiate renewals on
Xfinity Charter and Cox these are three
different cable carriers Fox News is the
only commercial news and even you could
even go further than that uh commercial
TV channel that doesn't actually need
ads because they make a lot of their
money
because if you have a cable subscription
even if you don't like Fox News even if
you don't watch Fox News
some of your monthly bill goes directly
to Fox News behind ESPN Fox News is the
second most expensive channel on every
cable bill you can't change that
consider the situation where you now
have a beleaguered Fox News to put it
lightly
in the middle of a defamation trial
and they are going to have to go and
negotiate with these cable carriers and
say we want the same amount of money per
subscriber that you're giving us now or
we want even more money per subscriber
than you're giving us now and a lot of
these subscribers are going to look at
Fox potentially and say wait a second
it's not even really clear much of our
customer base wants your channel here's
evidence that not that many people are
watching and in addition you guys are
hugely damaged right now we don't even
know what the future is of Fox News the
last thing we're going to do is commit
to paying however many dollars a month
you want us to pay this is a parallel
story to the Dominion lawsuit that could
be a disaster for Fox News and we're
going to be watching it as well the
trial will not be televised many people
writing to me saying David will it will
it be streamed live it will not but
there will be reporters in the courtroom
and we are going to get daily updates
let's see how the first day goes
Democrats are increasingly turning some
are saying on Democratic senator from
California Diane finds Stein and
demanding that she resign let me remind
everybody what is going on and there's a
lot of sad stuff going on in this story
Dianne Feinstein is currently the
longest serving member of the U.S Senate
she is 89 years old she is she has
announced she is not seeking re-election
in 2024. there have been many concerns I
want to be as respectful as possible but
also be accurate there have been many
concerns for years now about Dianne
Feinstein's cognitive State there are
public examples tough to watch I admit
public examples of Dianne Feinstein
asking a witness during a senate hearing
a question
hearing an answer from the witness and
then looking down at her papers and
asking the exact same question a second
time seemingly forgetting that she just
asked that question there are endless
reports from staffers and people in DC
who work at the Senate saying Dianne
Feinstein regularly will meet someone
that she has met many times before even
recently and has no recollection of
having met that person so listen I mean
we don't have a diagnosis here but there
have been concerns for years about this
as far as Dianne Feinstein goes it is
the right decision at this point she had
a great run to not run for re-election
in 2024. what has surfaced uh in the
wake of this is that there is a primary
in California in which three members of
the House of Representatives uh have
decided to run for Dianne Feinstein's
senate seat that's Adam Schiff who we've
interviewed uh Barbara Lee who we're
going to interview and Katie Porter who
we would like to interview but so far
has not responded to our requests you
can't run for House and Senate at the
same time meaning that while all three
of them Barbara Lee Adam Schiff and
Katie Porter who are mid 70s early 60s
and around 50 years old respectively
while they are all competing for the
senate seat
their congressional seats are now going
to be open because they can't run for
both at the same time
Dianne Feinstein on top of this as is
reported by Newsweek has recently been
out with shingles and this is
particularly impactful because Dianne
Feinstein is on the Judiciary Committee
and when you have such a divided
government the way we have right now
where Democrats barely control the
Senate judicial appointees are one of
the relatively few ways that Democrats
can assert power use their majority and
try to assist Joe Biden in getting
things done because of Dianne
Feinstein's absence from that committee
it has effectively made it impossible
for Senate Democrats to continue
confirming Joe Biden's judicial
nominations so both because it would
potentially allow a different dynamic in
the primary which would be better for
Democrats and because of this issue on
the Senate Judiciary
more and more Democrats are saying that
Dianne Feinstein should resign right now
if Dianne Feinstein did resign and
Farren cousins talked about this one
filling in for me last week to some
degree the governor of California
currently Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom would get to replace a point a
replacement to fill the vacancy now you
have to understand that there are
different Dynamics in California
depending on how long it is until the
next general election if Dianne
Feinstein were to resign within six
months of the general election there
wouldn't be a special election for the
seat you would just wait until
um uh the the general election when you
have under I'm sorry when you have more
than 180 days left then you would do a
special election right now because we
have more than 180 days until the 2024
uh election if Dianne Feinstein resigned
today
um you would see the appointment by
Gavin Newsom and then you would see a
special election that is potentially a
much better path forward both number one
because of its impact on the Senate
Judiciary Committee and number two
because it might actually change the
game with regard to so many Democratic
open seats in the House of
Representatives that increasingly
Democrats are saying that is exactly
what should be done uh it doesn't appear
as though right now there is Big
momentum for Dianne Feinstein to
actually do that and it's unclear
whether that is going to change the
other aspect to this that's being
discussed is what about appointing a
replacement on the Judiciary Committee
for Dianne Feinstein I don't have a lot
of news to give you about that right now
but it is certainly something that is
being discussed my leaning right now
is that it would probably be a good idea
for Dianne Feinstein to resign
what exactly the timing of that would be
and this issue of the replacement versus
getting back to the Senate Judiciary
Committee I don't know it's not about
again it's not about stigmatizing it's
not about making fun of any it's not
about any of these things it's about a
political expediency and Feinstein has
had an incredible run in the Senate has
accomplished so much iconic in so many
different ways nothing is being taken
away from her in my mind if she did
resign uh Republicans are jumping all
over this and saying she should not
resign and now Democrats are being bad
in some way by urging her to do so this
is of course Republicans concerned only
with self-preservation and realizing
that it's actually been a great thing
for them that Joe Biden's judicial
nominees have been held up as a result
of this so I I quite frankly could not
care less what Republicans uh say they
just want whatever is best for them it
does seem overall that what's best for
the Senate and what's best for Democrats
would would be for Dianne Feinstein to
resign I'm willing to change my mind if
you disagree with me simply let me know
in a comment in an email in a tweet
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David Pacman show is an audience
funded program we primarily depend on
your support to fund what we do to pay
staff salaries health insurance
connectivity the plants that are behind
me all of it yes all of it is funded
directly by you you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
single day for our members called the
bonus show we also offer commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
whether you prefer to listen or watch
both are made available commercial free
to you we also do a members only Town
Halls the next one is coming up soon we
also have a sound board a member sound
board with a lot of the clips I play on
the show off of my soundboard thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman well easy there Alex uh those are
made available to our members as well on
the David packman show website you can
sign up at joinpakman.com it's a great
great thing Elon Elon Musk was
interviewed by Tucker Carlson and the
interview goes horribly wrong now I have
to tell you that there is an irony
to
the contingent that has become the
strongest Defenders of Elon Musk and I'm
going to explain why in a moment but one
of the most notable things about this
interview billed as a two-night special
night one was last night night two is
tonight so if you just couldn't get
enough last night there will be more of
this tonight much of the interview was
spent by Tucker Carlson just sucking up
to Elon Musk and you do get the sense
you know Tucker in those Dominion voting
systems texts exposed as hating Trump
passionately you get the feeling that
Tucker is really desperate for Elon to
like him and much of what that includes
is Tucker doing the maniacal laughter
when Elon tells pretty mediocre jokes uh
check this out how did it get this way
you funded it at the beginning what
happened yeah well that would be ironic
but Faith the most ironic outcome is
most likely it seems
um
that's good that's actually a friend of
mine Jonah came up with that one I
actually have a slight variant on that
which is the most entertaining outcome
is the most likely but that's
entertaining as viewed from a third
party viewer
hi uh so this this was a lot of the
interview it really was and we're going
to get to more substantive things but I
I later in the interview I tuned back in
and Tucker is still sucking up to Elon
Musk New York Times of their of their
badge this morning and then you called
them diarrhea
you did you did I'm just I'm just
quoting you you you described that their
defeat as a diarrhea I said this is a
Twitter code Twitter callings of diary
okay it's not literally diarrhea but no
it's uh you know it's a metaphor um
hey okay so very entertaining to Tucker
as you can see and it's all great and
very very exciting eventually the
subject matter did turn to Twitter now
Twitter by any objective measure I hate
to go back into toilet humor but it's
been flushed significantly since Elon
Musk took over
um advertisers fleeing Twitter
engagement down this disastrous for you
feed that promotes mostly right-wing
nonsense Twitter blue where you can pay
to be verified and that went completely
backwards it's been very bad and
arguably uh based on not even arguably
based on the belief that Elon Musk was
trying to raise money at a 20 million
dollar valuation you can make the
argument that Twitter's value has
declined by more than 50 since Elon Elon
Musk purchased it okay so here Elon Musk
says he's sort of in The Matrix because
he's been heavily on Twitter since 2009.
since I've been a heavy Twitter user
since 2009
um
my it's it's sort of like I'm in The
Matrix I mean I can see like things do
things feel right do they not feel right
what what tweets am I being shown as
recommended uh
like I get a feel like what accounts are
making comments uh where are the
comments uh eerily similar yeah
um and uh he's really he's really
managing by feel which is interesting
given that these are the facts don't
care about your feelings people you look
at the account and it's just obviously a
fake photo and uh you know uh that it's
just obviously a bot cluster uh over and
over again so I started to get like just
more and more uneasy about the the
Twitter situation yep he was uneasy and
as you can see here from Tucker's
expression Tucker is very concerned you
can tell from Tucker's expression that
he's very very concerned about this the
topic of Twitter's role in upcoming
elections did come up and Elon Musk says
that not only in domestic elections but
even internationally Twitter is going to
play a major role I'm just saying but
you're kind of exposed in your other
businesses so this is just in case
reviews aren't following this
this is not you're not just like a
journalist taking a stand on behalf of
the First Amendment you're a guy with
big government contracts giving the
finger to the government do you think
um
Twitter will be as Central to this
presidential campaign as it was in the
last several I think it will play a
significant role in elections not just
domestically but internationally the
goal of new Twitter is to be
um as fair and even-handed as possible
by the way doesn't new Twitter sort of
remind every anybody else of New Coke
this was a disaster corporate disaster
where Coca-Cola
had a new Coke and I've read about it in
so many business case studies I don't
remember what the differences were how
it was flavored or sweetened or was it
the Colorado then there was like Clear
Pepsi
all new Twitter it's you're calling it
something but really it's just sort of
like bad twitter uh so not favoring any
political
ideology which is hard to believe given
that the for you feed is almost
exclusively right-wing propaganda uh
just um
yeah being being uh being fair at all
yeah the topic then turned to artificial
intelligence an interesting topic and I
actually do think Elon Musk has we
finally have gotten to something where I
think Elon Musk has interesting things
to say let's listen to what he said
about AI although it's a little bit uh a
little bit woo-woo it is fundamentally
profound in that the
the smartest creatures as far as we know
on this Earth are humans
um is a defining characteristic yes
we're obviously uh weaker than say
chimpanzees are less agile
um but real smarter
so
uh now what happens when something
vastly smarter than the smartest person
comes along in Silicon form right that's
pretty scary at least as far as Elon
Musk wants you to be concerned so his
idea is to create rather than chat GPT
truth GPT truth essential not truth not
truth truth GPT
we're going to start something which
you're called Truth gbt or
a maximum truth seeking AI that tries to
understand the nature of the universe
and I think this this might be the best
path to Safety in the sense that an AI
that cares about understanding the
universe uh it is unlikely to annihilate
humans because we are an interesting
part of the universe there you go now
this stuff is actually sort of
interesting the the the problem with the
entire interview is obviously the sort
of Hero's welcome that Elon Musk is
getting from people like Tucker Carlson
despite the fact that
listen I I don't I don't take the side
that Elon Musk is some extreme
right-wing nut
who is aligned with the hardcore Maga
right on every issue in fact the truth
is very different and it's interesting
to see how many of the people now
defending Elon Musk and sort of
fanboying out around him hate electric
cars and Elon Musk of course owns Tesla
think space exploration is a really
stupid waste of money and Elon Musk has
SpaceX like it's not lost on me that
Elon Musk is actually involved in a lot
of really interesting companies that are
antithetical to what many on the right
want I've also said that I'm a long time
I I used to own Tesla stock for years
and years although I've gotten out of it
now and I'm a long time Tesla driver
although I do plan to go in a different
direction when my current lease is up
for reasons I've explained that have
nothing to do with Elon Musk
specifically so I don't have this kind
of black white view of Elon Musk the
real issue with musk right now
is that through whatever series of
events is it kind of cozying up to Joe
Rogan and Texas Republicans like Greg
Abbott and just kind of being in that
environment and this has shifted his
view or based on who is signal boosting
him on Twitter he's sort of like become
uh adjacent to some horrible right-wing
people for whatever reason he's getting
the hero's welcome from the right at
this point in time and he is expressing
some uh pretty horrifying views
including like everybody should vote for
republicans in the midterms and all
these different things but the irony
isn't lost on me that he also does stand
for at least as far as many of his
businesses go things that the right
actually hates and yet they love them
because of the heroes welcome that
right-wing media has decided that he
should get so that was only night one of
this Blockbuster interview with Tucker
Carlson Knight 2 will be tonight if
there's anything interesting I'll have
it for you tomorrow the Trump team is
Raging over poll numbers that
increasingly show Donald Trump failing
in swing states where Ron Des Sanctus is
actually doing pretty well there's a
Newsweek article that summarizes it
Donald Trump's campaign team has
dismissed the finding of a poll that
suggests Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
would be the preferred 2024 candidate
against Joe Biden in key swing States
the Newsweek article writes a survey
from Republican firm public opinion
strategies shows that DeSantis who isn't
even officially running yet but is
expected to announce soon would beat
Biden in Arizona and Pennsylvania in a
hypothetical 2024 Face-Off by 48-42 and
45 to 42. poll of 500 registered voters
in Arizona and Pennsylvania also showed
Trump would lose to Biden in the key
States if they faced off again in 2024.
so the uh the the Trump War Room account
is just attacking the poll they put out
a tweet saying quote public opinion
strategies POS try desperately for days
to try to pitch this fake poll to other
outlets but they refused to disclose
disclose their ties to other 2024
candidates and would not release their
crosstabs data truly a POS poll now I
have to tell you the reality is this is
not a unique result I've been telling
you for a while that the polling
suggests that while Trump is doing
really well in the primary polling
DeSantis does better against Biden in
much of the general election polling and
if you take a look at recent polls uh
you see that for example in a morning
consult poll Biden leads to santis by
one but Biden leads Trump by three
that's a general election poll if you
look at that uh so then we have the
public opinion strategies poll
um there's a whole bunch of different
polls you can look at where Biden does
generally better against Trump with a
few exceptions so really the dynamic
here isn't unique to the POS poll most
polls right now suggest that Republican
voters are supporting the guy who would
do worse against Joe Biden and that's a
problem that the Republican party needs
to deal with one or two more of these
and he'll start calling voter fraud a
year and a half out and we'll deal with
that when we come to it but this is this
is a a problem of its own making
DeSantis by all measures would perform
better in a national race against Joe
Biden but can DeSantis actually get
himself into that position the
Republican primary polling increasingly
suggests that DeSantis cannot win a
National primary against Trump and we
are going to continue following those
numbers but the Trump team for now
Furious that anybody would dare to
report on that poll
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today I'm going to be speaking with
James underdown who's executive director
for the center for inquiry West in Los
Angeles and the chair and founder of the
center for inquiry investigations group
he's also the host of the upcoming web
series skepta lab the bunk stops here
James really great to have you on I
appreciate it yeah my pleasure thanks
for having me on so one of the things
that your organization has done is you
have offered money five hundred thousand
dollars
for definitive proof of superpowers or
of a supernatural ability
and the money continues to be available
it's never it's never been collected on
so let's first to understand what are
the parameters of the offer
well yeah the offer is half a million
dollars for anyone who can prove
paranormal ability under scientific test
conditions and that means that you can't
just call us up and say you shot a video
of something weird happening send me a
check or just take it on their word
alone you have to be able to show up
show us in person and control conditions
mean that we're going to make sure to
the best of our ability that you're not
cheating or using some
ulterior means to achieve whatever
effect you're talking about okay how
many let's go through the funnel how
many people have gone through the proper
process of applying
well uh average a couple years ago we
had over 250 applications
we average between one and two hundred
applications a year and usually it does
Whittle down when people find out what
they're going to have to do
I think it self-eliminates the people
who are planning to cheat okay
um so and in fact
as long as I'm on that subject no one
has ever tried to cheat during a test
anyone who shows up actually believes
that they have these superpowers so
um but the but it goes from so it goes
from 100 to 200 a year applying and we
only test like probably half a dozen by
the time all is said and done and
everybody understands each other the
negotiations we figure out what the test
is going to be what they say they can do
what we're comfortable with and uh then
We're Off to the Races so the fact that
people don't try to cheat suggests that
these are true believers they genuinely
believe they have whatever power they
claim to have
absolutely uh so far 100 percentage of a
hundred percent of them now of course we
do plan
for people cheating so we we treat
everyone as if you know we close off
these Avenues of cheating but yeah
everyone who shows up thinks they're
going to succeed and a lot of them are
really sort of surprised that you know
they can't
Define Millions to one odds in in their
telepathic ability okay so let's talk
about that when they fail
give us a sense of some of the reactions
do do does anybody say hey you know what
I actually can't do this thing or do
people blame the test conditions do they
say it was an off day
yeah there's I mean I I keep saying I'm
gonna start this the big book of excuses
yeah a lot of them say you know too much
skeptic energy in the room right
some of them say oh this test wasn't
fair even though they agreed to it you
know five minutes earlier
some of them it takes a few days for
them to to say that they were cheated or
somehow wronged
um you know so it varies there and let's
see so we've been testing people at this
point for 23 years
and there are probably been two or three
who have come back and said you know
maybe I need to rethink this a little
bit and reconsider what's going on
what sorts of claims have you tested are
there types that are the most common
ones
yeah probably the most common test we do
is telepathy so this is people thinking
that they can
project their thoughts into someone
else's mind that's most common some
people think that they can receive
thoughts lately we've been getting a lot
of people who they say they can
telekinesis is a big one so the ability
to move something with your mind without
touching it physically or anything so a
lot of people have been sending in
claims about moving clouds or doing
things to the sky
um
Dowsers we've tested a couple of Dowsers
uh some healers it's it's really all
over the map some people I mean we've
had people say that they could create a
rainstorm in the middle of a desert
um so like for that one do you go out to
the middle of the desert
well what we in these sort of predictive
sort of claims
we make it very clear that look you know
this can't be in the Amazon jungle it
can't be on an island in Hawaii it's got
to be somewhere that doesn't have rain
very often you have to predict the exact
time
in the exact place that this is going to
happen so we close these windows down so
it's not just a chance occurrence of
something that would happen anyway right
um how do you deal with I mean I'm
guessing although you can tell me if my
assumption is wrong that sometimes
people who are struggling with mental
health issues come to you and say I can
do this that or the other thing how how
does that happen how do you deal with
that it actually happens fairly commonly
especially with the telepaths so if
you're experiencing voices in your head
you're seeing some hallucination or
you're convinced that everyone can hear
your thoughts or that uh you know you
can hear their thoughts those are
symptoms from the DSM the diagnostical
statistical manual from the mental
health world yeah those are known
conditions and symptoms
so you know we we try to gently suggest
to people
um what you're experiencing is
consistent with some forms of mental
illness please consider that that may be
what's going on here we'll test you
anyway yeah but um know that this is you
know probably what's happening and by
the way
this isn't just me some blaming saying
this we have three psychologists on our
team and a psychiatrist so they're all
in full agreement that these are common
symptoms that people suffering from
mental illness sometimes uh experience
when people
um come in there are there are instances
of this sort of thing where the people
who assert these abilities will say that
they are by their nature not really
testable in this way now of course the
problem for organizations like yours is
that well then then we're dealing in an
unfalsifiable type of claim it's I'm
asserting this and it's not even the
type of claim you can evaluate do you
what do you get some of those and then
are you just not able to move forward in
that case yeah so it could be so some
people say that you know uh this just
happens every once in a while and I
can't put my finger on it I say when we
say say look we're not going to follow
you around 24 hours a day right you have
to be able to do this sort of on demand
so
um yeah it's just uh by the nature of it
um we're not going to fly to you in
Istanbul and you know spend six weeks
with you until this crops up again so
and by the way we do we test people from
all over the world just the other day we
tested a guy who was in Spain
who said he could hypnotize us into
making
us wall our eyes up into our head you
know like here going into a coma or
something yeah so some of these things
can be tested via Zoom or Skype or
whatever and uh we're willing to do that
if it if the test lends itself to that
that's convenient so you don't have to
necessarily fly around to then have your
eyes not roll up into the back of your
head
yeah that could be dangerous if you're
on the road
um so the new show skepta Lab the bunk
stops here it debuts in just a couple of
days I believe with three episodes on
telekinesis astrology and telepathy yeah
we're we're we started shooting this web
series you know we've been doing this my
group the center for choir
investigations group has been doing this
for 23 years now since 2000 and you know
we just decided to we have these
scads of experiences with these people
and the benefit of Decades of
information from uh the committee for
skeptical inquiry uh skeptical Enquirer
magazine all these people that we work
with and are a part of
we thought why not try to get some of
this debunking information out there
uh we actually got a little bit of a
grant to help us out with getting it
produced
and I know some people here in Hollywood
uh who are mostly on our side in terms
of getting Science Education out to the
public so you know we got some of these
celebrities to help out and they're
funny and so we get the information out
there with a little bit of humor and
then bring in some experts too to add to
the mix and and really try to convince
people that the stuff isn't what it
seems to be yeah I I love this stuff so
I'm really looking forward to it
astrology in particular is interesting
because with a lot of that that's about
personality traits and vague horoscopes
and these kind of Barnum type statements
what how do you debunk that
yes some of the things are are a little
tricky astrology was kind of fun we had
the help of Julia Sweeney who was a star
on Saturday Night Live a while back
and one of the things we did was we went
out to Hollywood Boulevard and set up a
table and said free astrology readings
and we put all the star signs and little
bins in front and people came up and got
there reading and read it on camera then
they scored the reading and said you
know how well did we did it do on
describing you the Libra that it
pretends to describe and they're giving
it nines and tens out of ten and then
we'd say okay now pick up an Aries and
it's the exact same
astrology reading star reading
so what does that tell you and a lot of
them admitted right on the spot you know
that you could write something that
applies to just about everybody and it
really isn't predictive at all it's just
a general statement well written toward
that end yeah and what's interesting
about that is in some sense you could
say that doesn't really debunk it
because if you just write a statement
that applies to most people everybody
would accept it I guess there would be
an another way to test it which would be
with different statements and and kind
of like
randomizing them and controlling you
know you could do a more complex test
too I'm sure right right you could you
could set up you could get 12 people
together and say okay talk to them a
little bit and pick out which one is the
Sagittarius right you know based on your
discussion but we added one other thing
to this discussion and and this is what
we try to do on skepta lab is we got
Phil play who is a working astronomer
and we said you know look talk about
these these constellations out there
which are meant to be the driving force
behind astrology talk about you know the
influence the physical influence they
have on Earth and Phil went and and
talked about how far they are the fact
that just because it might look like a
crab up in the sky doesn't mean the
stars are anywhere near each other
they're not the same distance or
anything
um he talked about the gravitational
pull of you know like a boss going by
who as as a bigger gravitational pull
than you know some star light years away
so there's a lot of other there's
multiple ways to think of why astrology
is is not real do you get into not so
much
um
more in the direction of some of the
medical stuff like for example you know
acupuncture is one that's been looked at
extensively and it seems as though in
most tests so-called sham acupuncture
works as well as quote real acupuncture
the idea being that the process of
having someone listen to your symptoms
and then maybe the Endorphin release
from the from the needles no matter
where you place them does have an effect
but it's no different with real version
do you get into that stuff at all
uh we do
um you know we're not my group isn't
involved in that sort of research per se
but yeah you're right I mean there are
aspects of a lot of the faith healing
kind of stuff and the alternative
medicine sort of stuff that is you know
the power suggestion the placebo effect
have a great deal to do with people
feeling better now we do test healers
and in fact
um just a month or two ago we had a guy
come in to test for the half million
dollars who said he could heal a lipoma
on one of our guys neck it had a little
lipoma on there so we measured it and we
got all these cameras you know watching
it as he's as he's doing it and he
couldn't do it so you know if you can if
your claim is that you can heal it on
the spot and have visual
incontrovertible evidence right now that
it's healed that's fine but you know you
get these you get like Benny Hinn and
these televangelist healers who say
they're making
uh they're healing people and we just
punch a lot of holes and why that's not
really happening what happens to all the
video footage of these failed tests
um you know we're getting better at
since we got the cameras for skepta lab
we're trying to get a little bit better
we are we do shoot a lot most of this
stuff
um but I don't know how to edit or
anything so it's sort of being stored
right now and we're using some of it for
the skepta labs okay and we'll use it in
the future as well I hope it's it's
fascinating stuff so if there's someone
in the audience there is a 500 000
reward available to you and you can find
out more by looking into the center for
inquiry we've been speaking with James
underdown the upcoming web series
debuting in just a couple days is
skeptilab the bunk stops here James
really appreciate your time today
thanks for having me on David it's been
a pleasure
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Florida
Governor Ron desantis's war with Disney
World has now gone up yet another notch
with DeSantis threatening to build a
state prison right next to Disney World
which is hard to even say with a
straight face that this guy is so petty
and so vindictive but he is let me
remind you the back story here Disney
faced internal pressure some time ago
to come out and criticize what is known
as the don't say gay bill in Florida
and the don't say gay bill in Florida is
this Bill signed into law which places
restrictions on what can be taught in
Florida classrooms about gender identity
and about sexual orientation as applied
to kindergarten through third grade
there was internal pressure uh at Disney
for them to come out and say we are
against this law
so Disney did that and DeSantis and
Florida Republicans flipped out they
said that Disney is going woke and they
subsequently decided to punish Disney
including by taking control of that
District which basically operated as a
private municipal government by Disney
and it contained Walt Disney World and
some other parks and this has continued
to grow and grow and grow this is not
really a battle I think DeSantis can win
because even though I hate theme parks
I'm aware that tons of people love them
and tons of people love Disney and the
movies and and Disney is generally very
well liked and so this is a risky thing
for DeSantis to do in addition now to
saying that he is going to start sending
inspectors to look at the rides at Walt
Disney World he now threw out the idea
during an event yesterday that maybe he
will build a prison next to Disney World
take that District you know one of the
things they tried to do was was put
restrictive covenants on the land that
the district owns So if you look at this
whole special district Walt Disney
Corporation obviously owns a lot of it
but the district owns other land you
know quite frankly I wasn't even
thinking about that land uh this was not
something that was really important one
way or another we just wanted them to
live on the same rules pay the debt pay
the taxes all that stuff oh but come to
think of it now people are like well
there's what should we do with this land
and so you know it's like okay kids I
mean people have said you know maybe
maybe have another maybe create a state
park maybe try to do more Amusement uh
Parks uh someone even said like maybe
you need another state prison who knows
I mean I just think that the
possibilities are are are endless and so
that is now going to be analyzed to see
what would make make the most sense okay
so he's it's we're having fun he's
joking the crowd's laughing it's all
super super interesting
this should actually be chilling this
shouldn't send a tingle down your leg
the way uh Chris Matthews once said this
should really send a chill down your
spine because what we are talking about
here is a guy who claims to have an
ideology
of not interfering with businesses being
against regulation
uh welcoming the tax revenue that comes
from businesses I mean what we're
talking about like the state's largest
tourist attraction by far and
antagonizing them is certainly an
interesting economic and political
decision but this is yet another example
it's another data point of how they
immediately and with total Reckless
abandon will get away from their stated
principles if it's not convenient or if
they're upset or if they want revenge or
if they want to ruin somebody's day
because they don't like politically the
things that are going on he is openly
using his political power
he has already done it and he is
threatening to do more of it against his
perceived enemies including corporate
enemies this is extraordinarily
dangerous stuff and despite all the
claims that it's the Democrats that want
to over regulate and hurt business and
all these different things
I've never seen anything like this
openly and overtly and brazenly so is he
literally going to propose building a
state prison right next to Walt Disney
World I don't know maybe maybe not it's
not totally clear but this is exactly
the stuff that we've been talking about
when we say these are not only
Hypocrites but they are dangerously
dangerously hypocritical and remember
it's all over don't say gay that's how
this all started Disney said hey we
don't like this everybody's welcome here
by the way Walt Disney World I've never
again I've been to Disney once when I
was like 18. I guess they're known for
all sorts of corporate events where you
can I don't know if the park is closed
down or what but they do everything from
corporate events to Pride day to gay
weekend or whatever else the case may be
it's also profitable for Disney whatever
you assess to be Disney's political view
like does Disney have a political view
is Disney Pro gay I don't know but they
certainly know
that their bread is buttered by all
sorts of different people including LGBT
groups and tourists and travelers and
whatever else the case may be so this is
as much out of self-preservation as it
is about whatever Disney thinks is right
and fair and good I don't know that
DeSantis can actually win this one but
it's certainly clear he's willing to try
just about anything in order to take a
shot at that here is something just
unbelievable that this is I don't even
Donald J Trump what do you think of that
sounds like an insult right sounds like
something that detractors of Trump would
say Greg stuby a republican congressman
who has made the decision against the
wishes of Florida Republicans to come
out and endorse Trump now when on
Newsmax his big announcement and he says
I am proud to endorse Donald Trump yeah
and Rob I want to thank you for giving
me the opportunity to talk about this on
your show and I'm happy and honored to
endorse Donald J chump
this is this is such a backfire in so
many ways so let me give you the back
story of what's going on here NBC news
article Ronde this is from uh six days
ago Ron desantis's team tries to stop
Florida Republicans from endorsing Trump
the governor's team has reached out to
at least six Florida Congressional
Republicans over the past week trying to
stop the bleeding the idea here is as
follows DeSantis hasn't announced yet
he may announce at some point over the
next three to four months is what's for
some reason July keeps being talked
about okay
if a bunch of these Florida Republicans
jump out and endorse Trump right now
it's not great for DeSantis DeSantis is
going to want to build his base of
support with endorsements presumably
starting with a Florida Republicans Greg
stuby decided I'm going to take a stand
I'm going to get in Trump's good graces
I'm going to try to get an atta boy from
Trump so I'm gonna proudly go on Newsmax
and announce that I am indeed endorsing
Trump
and then you get his name wrong and not
only do you get it wrong you use an
insulting term chump yeah and Rob I want
to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to talk about this on your
show and I'm happy and honored to
endorse Donald J Trump
this is your big moment to get on
Trump's good side to try to get
attention barely anyone cares what Greg
stuby ever says and you go out there and
you call him a chump now he also
attacked Ron DeSantis and this is where
it starts to get a little bit more
interesting Beyond just the cartoonish
nature of chump
the attacks on DeSantis are also
starting to be coordinated that's that
is one thing that I I hear from a lot of
people that I know I got a lot of
friends in Florida and they they say
that when DeSantis talks about you know
or when they think this is going to run
they're mortified because they don't
want to lose him uh in the Sunshine
State
yeah it's uh he hasn't even been elected
re-elected for six months uh and while
we're in legislative session right now
and the state legislature is doing their
business uh he's in South Carolina and
Iowa I think he's up here in Washington
uh tomorrow meeting with people where
his focus should be in Florida
Floridians want him to be focused on
Florida that's what he signed up for his
job for re-election to do so this is
telegraphing and predicting what is
going to be a big line of attack from
anti-disantis Republicans they showed us
these cards they showed us that this was
the hand they were going to be playing
even before the election we had clips of
Kerry Lake and Marjorie Taylor green who
by the way want to be Trump's VP
um saying DeSantis needs to do his work
for the people of Florida DeSantis has
been re-elected to be the governor
DeSantis should commit to serving the
full term which DeSantis opted not to do
during his debate uh in the 2022
midterms so this is going to be a line
of attack this is a guy who should be
doing what he told Floridians he was
going to do he is disloyal or he is some
way doing the wrong thing by not staying
and serving his term this is going to be
a line of attack it's abundantly clear
will DeSantis announce I don't know
we'll know very soon we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 David P you
can call the voicemail number any time
of day and many people do here is a
caller suggesting you know David
maybe you're better looking off camera
maybe it's not really that bad take a
listen to this
so I was thinking your employers are
like television world so when somebody
is not like really great on television
like in real life maybe you're like
better looking than you are on camera
I don't know why I find this so funny
not just a lot of people are
and you know I feel like there's
something against people who just aren't
good on camera yeah and it's like
there's nobody holding you accountable
well listen I you should look at my
inbox there are many people holding me
accountable for my physical appearance
you should see uh many of those uh
people are peddling in anti-semitic
commentary about my appearance which I
will not indulge anymore specifically
right now but uh no no no plenty of
people are holding me accountable for my
physical appearance rest assured if you
were concerned we have a great bonus
show for you today we talked at the top
of the podcast about Democrats saying
Dianne Feinstein should resign
we are going to talk on the bonus show
about Republicans lining up to say
Dianne Feinstein should not be replaced
on the Judiciary Committee this is a big
issue it's becoming a huge flash point
in Joe Biden's first term and judicial
nominations secondly we are going to
talk about the Supreme Court and the
potential restoration of religious
liberty in the workplace those sound
like dangerous buzzwords don't they yes
absolutely they are and George Anthony
devolder Santos has announced he's
running for re-election to serve the
people of the what is that the Third
District of New York I believe
um why is he doing it does he have a
shot what the hell is going on with this
guy we will talk about all of these
stories and more on today's bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad we're gonna try
to make some money on the bonus show
join us by signing up at joinpakman.com
I will see you then
foreign